the Highlander franchise is a series of
stories based around one compelling
original idea a fight between the worlds
and mortals who have secretly walked
among us since the dawn of time the
original movie revolves around immortal
Connor MacLeod from his youth in the
fields of medieval Scotland to 1980s New
York City where the last immortals are
being drawn by destiny to fight each
other to the death as we work our way up
to the remake set to be held by John
wick co-director chads2 house key we're
catching up with the untold truth of
Highlander it came from the bathroom
from the dawn of time we came moving
silently down through the centuries
spoken sonorous ly by Sean Connery who
plays the immortal Ramirez the film's
brief introductory monologue tells you
everything you need to know as it turns
out Connery recorded the iconic intro to
the series in his bathroom which is why
it echoes so much so the next time you
hear that powerful intro just know it's
Sean Connery standing half-naked in his
vacation home holding the script in one
hand the phone and the other and trying
not to bump is knee on the toilet
that's great acting people bolting their
still unreleased Queen songs the value
of Queen and the original Highlander can
simply not be overstated
it's impossible to imagine the movie
without the band's music but despite how
heavily Queens music features in the
franchise there was never an official
soundtrack instead many songs from the
movie ended up on unofficial releases
and Queens twelfth studio album 1986 is
the kind of magic while the big numbers
are all there there are Queen songs in
the movie that have yet to make it onto
any album the most notable omission
being the band's cover of theme from New
York New York as it plays in the lead-up
to the climactic final battle
[Music]
today only about 40 seconds of the song
has been released allegedly Freddie
Mercury hated singing it which is why
it's never been released also it sounds
more than a little ridiculous
Christopher Lambert's peculiar accent
one of the most enigmatic and charming
things about the original Highlander is
Christopher Lambert's legendarily weird
accent which just like the actor is
impossible to pin down Christopher
mother the lord of the Apes Lord Rayden
and once Lord of Diane Lane look I had
sex with Diane Lane multiple times the
movie even references his unusual accent
intentionally or not when a police
officer notices McLeod's inflection and
pointedly asks him where he comes from
netting the cheeky reply to talk funny -
were you from lots of different places
this was less of an intentional acting
choice than simply a happy accident
reportedly the accent came as a result
of Lambert's limited grasp of English at
the time of filming though born in New
York he was raised and started his
acting career in France at the time of
Highlanders filming his only prior
english-speaking role had been an
inarticulate Tarzan who's only just
learning English not really an excuse
for a guy who's been around for hundreds
of years because it doesn't get much
weirder than this the blind Highlander
Christopher Lambert must have been
completely lost during the filming of
these movies in addition to being very
iffy with English Lambert couldn't
actually see much of what he was doing
neither
Lambert suffers from myopia a disorder
that blurs his vision and filmed all of
his work without as much needed glasses
it's one thing to just talk with your
eyes closed it's a very different way
more dangerous thing to conduct
hand-to-hand combat in addition to
nearly taking a tooth out a co-star
Michael Ironsides head during filming of
the sequel Lambert cut his own fingers
split open because he couldn't see a
swing coming it's kind of remarkable
that it took a whole movie and a half
before Lambert was injured couldn't they
just let the immortal wear glasses
there's a recut sequel what is there to
say about Highlander - the quickening
that hasn't already been spat by Roger
Ebert
way all of this insanity could have
added up to something that would have
made a great bad movie but Highlander
two was so crazily put together you get
the impression that a lot of the key
scenes were just never filled a movie so
bad it has to be seen to be believed the
puzzling follow-up received generally
terrible reviews no longer coming from
the dawn the time as ageless enigmas
Highlander 2 reveals the earthbound
immortals to actually be aliens from the
planet Zeist and sets the action on an
earth artificially darkened by a
man-made solar shield which is a plot
goofy and cartoonishly evil enough to be
used by the Simpsons a few years later
[Music]
because it was so bizarre Highlander 2
was essentially ignored in continuity
but there was another later cut that
aimed to improve the sequel's quality
marketed as the renegade version the
newer cut makes the movie better by
simply cutting out a lot of the weirder
elements that made the theatrical
released so awful it's still not a great
movie but it's not one of the worst ones
of all time either weird cameos it's
possible that you know Highlander better
from the long-running TV show rather
than the movie that's bonded starring
Adrienne Paul the series ran for six
seasons in the mid 90s a precursor to
other relatively cheesy fantasy series
of the time like Xena Warrior Princess
sir Hercules The Legendary Journeys the
series exists mostly as a cultural
artifact featuring wild celebrity cameos
from the likes of rock star Joan Jett
porn star Traci Lords and rowdy roddy
piper among others it's one of the main
reasons to watch the series today
because it's one thing to see a guest
star recite lines on Law & Order but
it's a completely different thing to see
say Scottish singer-songwriter Sheena
Easton swinging a sword around damn you
don't get MacLeod
there was another TV show barely
remembered now 1998 saw the release of
his short-lived spinoff to the series
called The Raven starring former Miss
America Elizabeth Grayson the series
followed the immortal thief Amanda and
her ex-cop buddy as they solved crimes
and sought redemption for past sins
general franchise fatigue caused the Ray
never really catch on rumors of
production difficulties and a reported
tryst with grace and and former
President Bill Clinton years earlier
killed the series The Raven ran for just
one season anding the highlander
franchise's live-action presents on TV
after a seven-year run there was an
anime there's a far fringe to the
highlander franchise where the
continuity starts to get even weirder
like the highlander anime movie which
actually scored positive reviews called
the search for vengeance the film was
written by highlander series alum david
Abramowitz which gives it a level of fan
credibility that many of the live-action
sequels can't even claim it's also
probably the only fringe media and the
highlander universe that might be worth
your time meanwhile highlander the
animated series is best left forgotten
as is the clunky game based on the
cartoon the 1986 game wasn't much better
either and in 2001 an MMO was in
development but eventually canceled yet
another game developed nearly a decade
later for next-gen systems was cancelled
in development leaving behind only a
remarkably on promising trailer the
moral of the story let's not dismiss the
remake okay could it be any weirder
worse or off-base than what's come
before probably not thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our youtube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]